cuánto tiempo ha transcurrido desde la
hora en el reloj de la izquierda a la
hora en el reloj de la derecha observa
que tenemos el reloj de la izquierda y
el reloj de la derecha ambos con
diferentes horas y lo que queremos saber
es cuánto tiempo ha pasado desde la hora
que vamos a leer en el primer reloj
hasta la hora que vamos a leer en el
segundo reloj además nos dicen que el
tiempo que ha transcurrido es menor a
doce horas y eso es de mucha ayuda ya
que nos dice que este reloj no puede
decirnos una hora del lunes y este otro
reloj decirnos una hora del miércoles o
algo así porque ya sabemos que no han
pasado más de 12 horas bien lo primero
que quiero que hagamos antes de fijarnos
en la diferencia entre estos dos relojes
es averiguar qué hora marcan estos dos
relojes así que vamos a leerlos en el de
la izquierda vamos a fijarnos primero en
la mansilla de las
recuerda que está la manecilla más corta
es la manecilla de las horas y si
observas esta está entre 6 y 7 entonces
la hora empezó hasta arriba y pasó todo
esto hasta llegar al 6 pero ojo no ha
llegado a las 7 entonces serán las 6 y
algo y de hecho vamos a averiguar
cuántos minutos han pasado no se podrían
ser las 6 15 o las 6 20 de hecho vamos a
averiguar cuántos minutos han pasado
ahora veamos la manecilla de los minutos
que es esta que tenemos justo aquí y si
observas esta manecilla vas a darte
cuenta de que empezó hasta arriba y ha
transcurrido todo esto entonces tenemos
5 minutos 10 minutos 15 minutos 20 25 30
35 40 y ya no llegamos a los 45 a partir
de los 40 vamos
de uno en uno entonces será 41 42 43 43
minutos han pasado después de las seis
en punto entonces tenemos como ahora 643
eso en el reloj de la izquierda ahora
vayamos al reloj de la derecha y si
observamos primero la manecilla de las
horas
vamos a observar que está entre 9 y 10
ligeramente después de las 9 entonces
van a ser las 9 horas y ahora vamos a
ver cuántos minutos han pasado después
de las nueve en punto y si nos fijamos
en los minutos justo aquí vas a poder
ver que han pasado cinco diez y uno más
once minutos después de las nueve
entonces el reloj de la derecha marca
las nueve con once ahora bien lo que
nosotros queremos saber es cuánto tiempo
ha transcurrido desde las 643
que fue nuestra primera hora hasta las
nueve con once que es nuestra segunda
hora y una forma de averiguarlo es
rompiendo el problema en pequeñas partes
es decir primero vamos a ver cuánto
tiempo ha transcurrido desde las 6 43
hasta las 7 en punto hasta las 7 en
punto y para eso vamos a fijarnos en
cuántos minutos pasarán desde que esta
manecilla esté justo aquí hasta que la
manecilla llegue hasta la parte de
arriba y si observas de aquí acá han
pasado dos minutos dos minutos y después
tenemos cinco diez quince minutos más
entonces para que la manecilla de los
minutos que empieza aquí llega hasta la
parte de arriba han pasado dos minutos
más 15 minutos o lo podemos escribir
como 17 minutos
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla y vamos
a escribir que han pasado 17 minutos de
aquí hasta acá pasaron 17 minutos 17
minutos ahora de las 7 en punto hasta
las 9 en punto vamos a pensar en cuántas
horas han transcurrido desde las 7 hasta
las 9 en punto y bueno observa que desde
las 7 en punto empezamos aquí en esta
parte de arriba y le dimos toda una
vuelta para llegar a las 8 en punto y
otra vuelta más para llegar a las 9 en
punto entonces en total de 7 en punto a
9 en punto son 2 horas así que déjame
escribirlo desde las 7 en punto
a las nueve en punto han pasado dos
horas
y finalmente vamos a fijarnos cuántos
minutos va a haber desde las nueve en
punto hasta las nueve con 11 minutos
bueno pues si nos fijamos vamos a ver
que han pasado cinco minutos 10 minutos
11 minutos más desde las 9 en punto
hasta las 9 con 11 minutos entonces de
las 9 a las 9 con 11 minutos podemos ver
que han pasado 11 minutos más
11 minutos más
así que en total desde las 6 43 hasta
las 9 con 11 cuánto tiempo ha pasado
bueno pues hay 17 minutos más dos horas
más 11 minutos así que podemos escribir
esto como dos horas como dos horas y
bueno ahora habrá que combinar dos
minutos y para eso vamos a sumarlos si
yo tengo 17 minutos y a esto le sumó 11
minutos cuando me va a dar 7 + 1 es 8 y
después uno más uno es 2 10 + 16 20
entonces me va a quedar en total 2 horas
y 28 minutos
28 minutos
para llegar de las 643 que es la hora
que marca el reloj de la izquierda hasta
las nueve con once que es la hora que
marca el reloj de la derecha